hey what's up my name is samuel leeds
and i want to introduce you to a guy he
is a property millionaire completely
financially free his name is ben from
portsmouth and he's going to share with
you in this video exactly how he built
up his wealth how he became financially
free and i really think you're going to
learn a lot of golden nuggets so why
don't you smash the like button
subscribe to the channel and ben thank
you so much for traveling down and
coming to my house today
thanks so much for having me it's an
absolute pleasure to be here samuel and
we've now uh we've known each other for
the past year and when we met you were
already a property millionaire
and you were already making a couple
thousand pounds a month
yeah but my goal was really to
absolutely smash that and to
go all out and push myself to the next
level which i think i've done i've been
in the academy since
june and i've added more properties my
portfolio i've more than doubled my
passive income in that time so yeah
really happy so far it's impressive
because
your portfolio has gone from you've gone
from a property millionaire to a
property multi-millionaire exactly yes
so it's um just over i think it's about
2.2 million at the moment but obviously
that goes up and down with uh with flips
and developments yeah as you know you're
kind of selling properties
all the time and taking all new
properties so it's um it does vary yeah
and you've also
your passive income was two thousand
pounds a month it's now gone up to about
five thousand pounds a month yeah it's
i've got some service accommodation
units which i've added in purely from
from my learning in the academy really
and the crash courses so um
bay very in the summer obviously it's
usually much more with tourists but even
in the winter as i say we're making
between i think it's between four and
five thousand at the moment yeah well
what i wanna ask you to start with ben
is
what was it that made you as already
somebody that was financially free
property millionaire and it sounds very
impressive
but but as you know um financially free
we go by the definition of when your
passive income covers the average uh
life so you were financially free you
were rich property millionaire again
sounds really impressive but a million
pounds is a lot less today than it was
20 years ago so what was it that is
someone that was already an experienced
property investor that drew you to come
to the training to like what why did you
connect with me why did you come down to
the crash course what was it that made
you do that well i actually i actually
saw the uh the bbc documentary years ago
interviewing when i was just starting
out and then i came across your training
a few years later after i was in
prophecy and
at the time i think
i probably got a bit too comfortable i
was in my job i was earning a good
salary my partner was earning and we had
time for buy to less so
we were kind of living the life we
bought our range rover we had our nice
house
but i was working kind of eight hours a
day at least every day it's not the life
i wanted i i have a very
entrepreneurial mindset and i really
wanted to build something for myself
with my own legacy
and i just let myself get too
comfortable i stayed in that job far too
long i think when i came across your
training
it pushed me to explore
other ways in which i could increase my
passive income and really achieve my
dream
in a way yeah um
so i i was made made for london in the
middle of the pandemic kind of um
mid-2020 i think it was
june or july 2020
and instead of going back
back to work i'd already attended one of
your crash courses i think online um
so i decided i opened the company and i
raised investment and i bought i bought
a brr project
it was a bit slow at the time and i
think i didn't realize i should have
been doing things to really increase my
passive income to replace my salary yeah
and instead i took on a slow burning uh
refurbishment and she did pay off that
house is now i've got a house for free
the investments back out it earns me
just under 1200 a month in rent and
profits about 600. wow and you managed
to put all your money out then yeah plus
two grand yes yes an additional two
grand for my for my time which was right
yeah so it's all i get paid for a house
very interesting what you said though
about um i mean i talk a lot about
uh fast pounds slow pounds
cash flow and and assets talk to me
about the difference and the importance
so that's really what the academy has
taught me is the need for for first
pound and the difference before i was a
typical slow buy tonight investor i buy
your property i was working like save
and i'd remortgage for deposits
coming into the
academy and learning from yourself
i've realized you can actually use other
strategies such as service accommodation
deal selling
hmos to really push your cash flow to
the next level so i turn one of my
traditional vitalettes
into a service accommodation house
it's a muse house so it's nice and easy
kind of lock up and leave we redecorated
re-furnished it and that went originally
as a vital air it was earning 800 a
month
and in the summer months it was just shy
of 3 000 pounds wow
so more than tripled yeah it's a huge
difference i mean it does vary
seasonally yeah of course but it's still
doing better than invite to that
fabulous
okay so since joining the academy then
which was about six months ago now only
and i know you've been in the world
you've come to the crash courses and um
for about a year and a half but since
joining the academy
what exciting deals have you done what
how have you managed to increase your um
your portfolio so much have you managed
to grow your cash flow so much so talk
to me about some of the deals you've
done so the first one i was already
working on a refurbishment so
a buy refurbished refinance
i didn't really understand what it could
be and i think it was
the crash course and then joining the
academy those first
nuggets of training and information that
pushed me to really
raise the uh the standard on that house
and get all of the money back out so
that was the first one which i completed
and it's left out
that investment we then purchased
another house which is currently going
through renovations
um
i also done a bit of deal selling and so
i sold a
brr deal i found it from a letting agent
which i use off-market and i sold it
through another um
estate agent slash sorcerer um
as an authority deal so so that's it's
about to go through now what was your
final film
it's about three thousand pounds okay
i'm splitting it with the co-source
there um cause at the time i i wasn't
registered i couldn't say it myself yeah
so we split the profit which is great i
mean fifteen hundred pounds in salary
for some people yeah
but literally doing nothing really
because you're out looking at properties
for yourself anyway exactly yeah and
i've done a favor in this if if this
unless i didn't buy it it's a lovely
house i would have bought it for myself
yeah and
so i've done that um but my main focus
is refurbishments i mean
um i i'm actually i was working as an
architect before so i'm qualified in
design so my i suppose speciality is
turning houses for quite a low cost in
something really special so um the next
deal i managed to do
i
i raised investor finance i'm working
with an amazing uh jv partner italian
morrow she's on the academy as well um
so she's invested in this deal
uh two of my friends a couple they've
actually trusted me and invested some of
their savings in the same deal and i
raised the bridging lane so we purchased
um
we purchased a house 175 000 um
investor deposit bridging loan for the
rest of it the it cost about
six thousand entitled to refurbish so
not a lot of money
um and it's just a green sale subject to
contract off market at 240 000. wow so
you bought it for 175. you spent six
grand on it yeah use other people's
money entirely exactly and then you're
selling it for 240 240 that's a huge
profit yeah so it will be just a bit
under 50 000 pound profit in the end
after the obviously bridging fees are
quite high yeah i've got estate agents
selling fees things like that so
i think pre-tax profit i reckon would be
in the region of 45 at the end
um
but yeah not not too far off my initial
estimates anyway and uh amazing it took
me
it was about seven weeks worth of work
in total and eight weeks exactly from
day to day from completion to sale and
where is this property that's important
so how did you manage in this booming
market
how do you manage to get such a good
deal in portsmouth on that property well
i actually work with a local guy he's a
director of an estate agent
investigation high news and he's set up
his own sourcing business so of course
he's
he knows everyone in proxy in the area
and he really does find some amazing
deals and i'm like i work with him quite
regularly
solve a deal together
um and we kind of help each other out so
he found this deal for me i paid him a
sourcing fee but i've made a fantastic
profit on it yeah and i guess as well i
mean i think that it's not just about
what you know it's really important to
have a good network around you
connections power team
success buddies i mean how important do
you feel that has been in your journey
to get into what you've achieved today i
mean it's all about accountability isn't
it i mean without the kind of
accountability of the other people on
the academy that i've met i mean
that's really pushing me seeing other
people's successes and being so happy
for them and wanting to push myself
harder and also meeting jv partners and
being inspired to raise finance um
it's just beyond valuable i think the
network is is everything as you say
network is your net worth yeah and it's
true so what was your job then
previously to full time in property so
yeah i'm i'm a qualified architect so i
was working as an architect in
chichester just before i was made
redundant yeah and before that i worked
as a commercial architect for a few
years in central london
and we actually
part of my journey was uh working in
london in the week and then every
weekend driving down to portsmouth and
kind of refurbishing my to-let
properties to try and build my portfolio
so i had quite a few years of working
very hard to try and build up and it
doesn't come easy as you all know
and i'm i actually do a lot of work
myself i've i have done throughout the
years i'm kind of
fairly good at decorating and diy things
like that so i mean part of my uh my
next um
challenge is going to be letting go of
that and perhaps outsourcing more for
work so i can grow my business to the
next level
so yeah i think that
background of architecture is actually
really happening with that and designing
designing properties to a really high
standard um
just choosing materials and colors and
layouts and
knowing how to get that right yeah
really benefited me what's your
strongest reason for doing all of this
stuff
there's so many i mean
um
i suppose originally i was probably a
little materialistic a bit money
orientated but it just
changes beyond belief i mean
so um i mean very recently actually my
grandmother she's got uh quite severe
dimensions she unfortunately decided the
head of social she she couldn't stand up
in her home anymore
so she's gone to a home and my parents i
mean they're middle class but they're
concerned obviously when her house runs
out with money that
if the home is too expensive the council
won't cover the cost so she's going to
encourage a home
which they will be able to afford but i
visited it and
the staff are amazing they're obviously
very very caring lovely people but the
standard of the home
it's not what i want for her this is an
amazing woman who's
looked after me as a child and taking
care of me
my whole life with my parents as well
but she deserves the best and i would
like to um
i'd like to be in a position where i
could fund her to have the best possible
dementia care available because i think
she deserves it and that's
something i'd like to do within the next
i say i mean in homes they cost a
minimum of about a thousand pounds a
week it's a huge amount of money for
most people so
realistically um within the next year or
so it's something i'd love to be able to
help out with
yeah and so so and then there's this
other thing so i'm i support charities
so i'm very passionate about equal
rights things like that so um
i'd love to be able to kind of
provide houses for refugees people
coming from countries where they don't
have the same rights that we do
um
that would be something i'd love to do
in future yeah um obviously supporting
my family and my partner is actually
it's british thai so we've got a nephew
out in thailand so um we pay for
international schooling for him which is
really nice um
yeah there's so many things i think
that's the thing isn't it money it's not
just about buying material things money
money gives you choices in life money
can it brings freedom it means you can
do things like you know provide your
grandma with the best care
look after your family support the
charities that you want to do and for me
it's a real it's a real honor it's very
feeling to be able to help people make
more money
like yourself that i've got at good
hearts and actually want to help people
what was it that out of all the because
you were you've been in property for
many years now i think you bought your
first pocket was it 2010
uh
2011 i think it was like something like
that yeah you've been in property for
many years um not not massively
dissimilar from when i bought my first
property in 2009 so it you've been in
property for almost the amount of time
i've been in property you've built up
quite a successful portfolio um what was
it that made you choose
my training over all the other trends
that you could why did you choose why
did you use my training
i think it's your energy and your
passion you can really see that and i've
been to your events and you don't get
bored other training events
with all due respect for them i've sat
there and i felt a little bit tired a
little bit bored when i've just gone to
their instructor events and i think your
training is full of energy
the networking is brilliant i just
really enjoy it the whole atmosphere is
it's really just pushes you to the next
level
and what's your experience being like on
the academy i know you're halfway
through now the year what's the
experience been so far
well i think i said it's the people and
the network which is everything and i
think having those people and the
friends that i've made and now the
academy networking course it just really
helps you to grow and you hold each
other accountable and it's worthless
obviously the training and the
information you get from that
so what's the next steps then for you
ben what are you hoping to achieve over
the next sort of six 12 months
okay so my goal by the end of 22 is to
be a cash millionaire so equity in cash
so i'm not too far off um
but i'd really like to push myself to
get there um
i want to
increase my cash flow so once i
finish the deals i'm doing now i'm
considering investing in maybe some
high-end hmos hostile hmo
on suites things like that so very very
nice standards um
and i've also got the idea of investing
perhaps overseas saying in thailand sa
in thailand would be absolutely amazing
and maybe start off with some kind of
smaller villas and build up from there
and you just got back from thailand how
long were you in thailand uh just over
two weeks this time okay great yeah um
so what would you say to someone
starting out in property that's maybe
where you were a couple of years ago or
even 10 years ago when you first started
i know you've made a lot of mistakes in
the other days you did some or not even
mistakes but you did a lot of deals
where you didn't make as much money as
you could have made knowing what you
know now
what advice would you give to your 10
year younger self
and
education first there's a lot i learned
from actually pursuing education which i
didn't know so i i read a few books and
i went into property but i was probably
quite naive i
i
i took out equity i bought a buy to that
and probably thought it would make me a
millionaire
overnight you know i mean kind of have
this idea of landlords in your head um
but
there's so many other ways you can get
into property you don't need a huge
amount of money these days you can
really you can do rent to rent you know
i've just myself taken on a corporate
let um as an sa just
almost as an experiment to try to
improve my cash flow and that's already
going well so that's something i might
pursue myself even though i've got my
own properties
taking one corporate
in the future to build cash flow is a
it's a really
it's a really strong idea a really good
business plan yeah
but i think
don't be scared just
dive in obviously you don't achieve
anything without taking action i know
people who said oh well
i want to get through all the training
first and then finish every single bit
of training then i'll invest
um
or
i just want to learn a bit more i want
to save a little bit more
you can take action now um i've made
mistakes um
in a way
i've kind of gone too slowly and being
passed i think i should push myself
harder in some ways
and
she said i've been in property a similar
time to you but i had quite a break from
buying my first house
in
in 2011 he said i then went back to
university finished my master's my
professional qualifications and worked
for a few years before i actually bought
my first buy to let
um
but i think
having a job and getting a mortgage is
still a really good way to get into it
you talked recently in your latest
financial uh
freedom um
movie about house hacking which is a
fantastic idea and i think a lot of
people they don't make compromises when
i bought my first house i moved from
santo in central london right out to the
edge of london to zone six commuted in
kind of 40 minutes on the train i bought
a house which had been empty for six
years needed refurbishment
and
signed it up and because of that we were
able to build equity and then later
release that and put it into property i
think it's all about making compromise
um
if you want to live
in the best area in a house which
doesn't need any work
and only immediately you're not
necessarily going to make any money yeah
and
you need to be willing to to work hard
and compromise yeah it's interesting
that you've got interest events because
a lot of people might think that rent
events is for people like just starting
out only but you've got quite a big
portfolio and you've got eight
properties right now that you that you
own is that correct yeah i've got eight
my own and i've just seen this corporate
that i've just taken on um which is
amazing but um
what was it that made you get into
entrance and how's the experience been
so far is it is it being harder than you
thought is it easier than you thought
this one was fairly easy um i mean i i
used the letting go sorry i already knew
i found the property i liked and because
they trusted me i already had that
relationship they spoke to the landlords
and helped me arrange that property and
at first i thought oh i've kind of
cheated a bit like i haven't called up
a landlord from open rent and done it
that way but actually
why do it the easy way if you've got
that contact if you know someone if
you've built relationships use them
there's nothing wrong with that yeah and
what kind of cash flow are you expecting
i know you need to look at it as a year
by year because every month will
vary a little bit for intervention but
what kind of um you know profit are you
expected to vacuum per month off that
one rental round and i would imagine in
the summer
probably
at least between 1500 and 2000 a month
you've seen a very good area in a lovely
uh it's like any shopping development in
in portsmouth near harbour but that's
huge i mean if that's making fifteen
hundred two grand that how many
buy-to-lets would you need to own
to to do that probably about free yeah
at least i mean an average buy to let
the average rent in the uk 750 take away
your mortgage your maintenance your
management but that one rents around is
it cash flowing positive already and
even just got it yes it is that's
incredible that must be a good feeling
yeah it's making
it's gonna make about five six hundred a
month i think january it's got actually
someone's taking it for a whole month
for january which is great because
january is a slow month yeah so um the
cost of the apartment is a studio in
6.50 and they're paying um i think it's
1200 for january incredible well you've
done super super well so um
so you're in property full time you're
financially free you've doubled your
portfolio are you doing nobody down
deals what will be your final piece of
advice or piece of wisdom that you would
share to anyone watching this to sort of
wrap up the interview
and i think just don't be
don't be scared i think if you've been
have back in the past and
for example i've had people
i don't know
i've been quite badly bullied in the
past i've been through a lot and instead
of being nervous i actually take that
and use it as motivation for the future
and i just it really helps me push
myself forward i think just just go for
it don't be um
don't be too scared i think just jump in
and well mad respect then to what you've
achieved it's a it's a real pleasure to
know i'm looking forward to our party uh
next week
and uh you know thanks so much for
coming on the show and for giving back
and inspiring other people you know
thank you
pleasure thanks for everything you've
done for me and for training and
everything yeah it's a real pleasure so
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope you found that inspiring i hope you
got a load of nuggets why don't you go
ahead and hit the like button subscribe
to the channel and if you want to come
down to the property investors crash
course that ben was talking about then i
have got good news for you i've got some
free tickets that i'm giving away uh
there is limited spaces so i'm gonna
leave a link in the description where
you can claim your free tickets to come
down meet me at the property investors
crash course get booked on and i'll see
you guys next time god bless